THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL --
TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
RAIL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROCK [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER EARN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
I'M BURKE [inaudible]
BY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
COLLEAGUES A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERSHIP AND OUR
GUEST BEYOND THE RAIL IN IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RICE WE WILL BE
LEADING PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG.
BY OUR NEW COLLEAGUE SENATOR
ARCHULETA.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
GRACIOUS AND LOVING GOD.
AS WE PRAY FOR ALL THOSE
SUFFERING FROM VIOLENCE AND THE
EFFECTS OF NATURAL DISASTERS.
ESPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ASK THIS WE MAY BE INSPIRED
TO GREATER ACTION AND HOPE.
BY THE WORDS OF REVEREND DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
SPOKEN IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN AS FOLLOWS.
WE CAN NO LONGER AFFORD TO
WORSHIP THE GOD OF HATE.
OUR BOW BEFORE THE ALTAR OF
RETALIATION.
WE ARE NOW FACED WITH THE FACT
THAT TOMORROW IS TODAY.
WE'RE CONFRONTED WITH THE FIERCE
URGENCY OF NOW.
IN THIS UNFOLDING CONUNDRUM OF
LIFE AND HISTORY.
THERE IS SUCH A THING AS BEING
TOO LATE.
WE STILL HAVE A CHOICE TODAY
[inaudible]
NONVIOLENCE COEXISTENCE OR
VIOLENCE CODE ANNIHILATION.
WE MUST MOVE PAST INDECISION TO
ACTION.
WE MUST FIND NEW WAYS TO SPEAK
FOR PEACE.
AND JUSTICE THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
A WORLD THAT BORDERS ON OUR
DOORS.
NOW LET US BEGIN.
NOW LET US REDEDICATE OURSELVES
TO THE LONG AND BITTER.
AND BEAUTIFUL STRUGGLE FOR AND
YOU WORLD A MAN.
LADY JOAN WOULD PUT YOUR HAND
OVER YOUR HEART TO OUR MEN AND
TO HONOR OUR MEN AND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM IN OUR VETERANS ACROSS
OUR BEAUTIFUL STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR WE
WILL START.
A SENATOR DODD DID YOU HAVE.
THE PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR
[inaudible]
SENATOR DODD.
ALL RIGHT AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
WE HAVE A PRESENTATION UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
CENTER LABOR COULD YOU.
COME ON UP.
WHERE THE HELL IS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS WE ARE
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR JACKSON AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES IT IS MY DISTINCT
HONOR.
AND PRIVILEGE AS WELL AS SORT OF
A SAD MOMENT. TO HONOR.
AN EXTRAORDINARY CALIFORNIAN AN
EXTRAORDINARY PUBLIC SERVANT.
EXTRAORDINARY GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL.
THE NOW RETIRED.
THE NOW RETIRED [inaudible]
CALIFORNIA IF [inaudible]
CAN PIMLOTT.
THOSE OF US WHO EXPERIENCED
FIRES SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
ELEVEN WORKED WITH HIM VERY
DIRECTLY BECAUSE AT THAT POINT
IN TIME JERRY BROWN IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN APPOINTED
HIM. TO TAKE OVER AS THE CAL
FIRE [inaudible]
DIRECTOR.
LITTLE DID HE KNOW OF COURSE AT
THAT TIME.
THAT THIS WAS GOING TO BE QUITE
A RIDE.
AND CERTAINLY DURING THE PAST
FEW YEARS.
HE HAS LED AN EXTRAORDINARY
ALMOST IN.
UNBELIEVABLE IN HUMAN.
EFFORT. TO FIGHT.
THE WILDFIRES THAT HAVE.
THIS MARCH TO OUR STATE.
WHICH HAVE CAUSED THE LOSS OF
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF ACRES
OF LAND AND MORE IMPORTANTLY.
THE LOSS OF WELL OVER A HUNDRED
HUNDRED AND FIFTY LIVES.
HE HAS LED THE MARCH.
WHEN MOTHER NATURE HAS ASSERTED
HERSELF WITH GREAT FURY?
ANYWAYS WHERE WE WHEN WE SAW THE
THE FIRE STORM COMING WE COULD
NOT BELIEVE.
THAT IT WOULD.
ULTIMATELY [inaudible]
NOT PREVAIL.
BUT DURING THOSE WEEKS THAT IN
MY OWN COMMUNITY IN SANTA
BARBARA VINTER COUNTIES FOR
FORTY DAYS WE FOUGHT WHAT WAS
THEN JUST A YEAR AGO.
THE LARGEST WILDFIRE IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY. TO A BEEN
SUPPLANTED TRUST A FEW MONTHS
AGO.
BY THE CAMPFIRE AND THEN OF THE
WOOLSEY FIRE WHICH CHALLENGED.
SO MANY OF OUR FIREFIGHTERS SO
MUCH OF OUR COMMUNITY.
HE DID THIS AS THE LEADER OF AN
ORGANIZATION.
THAT WAS TASKED TO DO SOMETHING.
THAT WAS TRULY TRULY SUPER HUMAN
I'M NOT GONNA GO INTO ALL THE
DETAILS OF HIS EXTRAORDINARY
CREDENTIALS.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU AND I KNOW
THAT THOSE WHO WILL BE SPEAKING
AFTER ME SHARE THE FACT.
THAT THIS MAN I DON'T THINK
SLEPT ONCE.
AND DESERVES THIS WELL EARNED
RETIREMENT BUT HE SAVED OUR
BACON ON SO MANY OCCASIONS HE
SAVED SO MANY LIVES THROUGH HIS
LEADERSHIP HE SAVES SO MUCH.
OF A STATE THAT COULD OTHERWISE
HAVE BURNED EVEN MORE THAN IT
DID.
THROUGH HIS EXPERIENCE HIS
EXPERTISE HIS COMMITMENT HIS
COURAGE AND HIS KNOWLEDGE.
OF HOW TO BEST DEAL WITH MOTHER
NATURE WHEN SHE WAS ON A RAMPAGE.
AND SO I WANT TO THANK HIM
PERSONALLY.
ON BEHALF OF MY CONSTITUENTS.
ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I KNOW HIS WIFE ISN'T HERE TODAY
BECAUSE SOMEBODY'S GOT TO WORK.
BUT MOM AND DAD AND SON ARE HERE.
AND FAMILY MEMBERS YOU KNOW WE
KNOW WE CAN'T DO THIS ALONE.
BUT HIS EFFORT HAS BEEN
UNBELIEVABLE AND IT IS WITH
GREAT RESPECT.
A GREAT HONOR THAT I WANT TO
SHARE WITH MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
ARE GOING TO BE SPEAKING AND
THEN PRESENT HIM WITH A
RESOLUTION.
ON BEHALF OF I THINK ALL OF US
FOR THOSE WHO DIDN'T SUFFER
THROUGH THESE OF VANCE YOU SAW
THEM HAPPEN.
THERE BUT FOR THE GRACE OF GOD
COULD HAVE GONE ANYONE.
AND FOR THOSE OF US WHO GOD
DIDN'T NECESSARILY GRAYSON WHO
CHALLENGED US WITH THESE FIRES
HE WAS THERE. TO HELP US THROUGH
THEM TO FIGHT THEM TO WIN THE
BATTLE AND HOPEFULLY IN HIS
RETIREMENT HE WILL LOOK BACK AND
BE SO PROUD OF HIS EFFORT.
AS WE ARE OF YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON'S.
NIELSEN.
NOT A PRESS.
CHEN.
I'M GOING TO MISS.
CAN'T THEM LIVE.
OR TWELVE O'CLOCK AT NIGHT
CONVERSATIONS OR FIVE O'CLOCK IN
THE MORNING CONVERSATIONS.
AND HE IS A LEADER OF AN AGENCY
WHO WERE ALWAYS ANSWER.
AND WOULD ALWAYS BE THERE FOR
YOU.
OVER THE YEARS I'VE SEEN MANY
[inaudible]
DEPARTMENT DIRECTORS.
IN THIS VERY DIFFICULT JOB.
BUT VERY FEW HAVE EVER COME AT
SUCH A CHALLENGING TIME.
ARGUABLY NONE EVER MORE
CHALLENGING THAN ON CAN
PENALIZES WATCH.
THE PRODUCT OF A LOT OF YEARS OF
MANY FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTED.
THE CATACLYSMIC FIRES OF NOW
CAUSES TO SUFFER SO VERY MUCH.
BUT HE WAS ALWAYS DEDICATED TO
PREPAREDNESS WITHIN HIS
DEPARTMENT.
THE TRAINING.
MOTIVATING RECRUITING GOOD
PERSON NOW.
AND TRYING TO GET THE BEST OF A
QUICK
MANY HOURS YOU SPEND IN OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND AGONIZING
OVER.
WHAT WE COULD DO TO HELP THEM
WITH THEIR EQUIPMENT AND THEIR
EQUIPMENT NEEDS YET ARE GREAT?
AS THIS WELL AS PROVEN.
AND THE NATURE OF THE FIRES THE
MAGNITUDE.
IT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE IN THE
SHORT RUN.
BUT I ALSO.
THIS BILL MIGHT WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR TENDING.
TO CLEANING UP IN MANAGING OUR
FORCING A WILD LAND SO WE DO NOT
ACCRUE.
THE ENORMOUS FUEL.
THE SO CONTRIBUTED TO THE
MAGNITUDE OF THESE FIRES WE'VE
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE WAY
TOO YOUNG KEN TO RETIRE I GO ON
TO SOME GOOD OTHER THINGS.
PLEASE REMAIN OUR FRIEND.
AND YOU REMAIN IN OUR STEAM WITH
A BIG THANKS. FOR ALL YOU GOOD
STEWARDSHIP.
CAL FIRE.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN
SENATOR DODD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
YEP.
I'D LIKE TO RISE IN. TO
RECOGNIZE DIRECTOR TIM MOTTS
DISTINGUISHED CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE.
MOVEMENT ON ME.
AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REPRESENTING LAKE COUNTY I GOT
TO KNOW DIRECTOR PMR DURING THE
DEVASTATING TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
FIRES.
DURING THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WORK PAVE WILDFIRES I
CONTINUE TO WITNESS THE
DIRECTORS TIRELESS LEADERSHIP.
AND DEDICATION.
HERE'S WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
THROUGH THE MOST CHALLENGING
FIRE SYSTEM PROFESSIONALLY AND
PERSONALLY AND ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT I WANT
TO THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH. FOR
YOUR SERVICE I WISH YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY ALL THE BEST IN YOUR NEXT
CHAPTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHIEF.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD SENATOR
MONNING.
THANK YOU A MADAM PRESIDENT I
ALSO JUST WANT.
TO OFFER MY THINK SOME BEHALF OF
THOSE I REPRESENT WHO FACED
FIRES MONTEREY COUNTY THIS SOBRE
HONEST THE CHIMNEY FIRE IN SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTY.
SANTA CRUZ SANTA CLARA COUNTIES
YOUR PRESENCE LITERALLY COMING
TO THESE FIRES ZONES HELPING IN
THE COORDINATION OF YOUR TEAMS.
BEING WILLING TO BE PERSONALLY
PRESENT TO REASSURE LOCAL
RESIDENTS LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AT CENTURY YOU'VE SERVED WITH
DISTINCTION YOU'VE INSTILLED
CONFIDENCE YOU KNOW MANY PEOPLE
LOOK AT GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND DON'T THINK THEY
EVER GET IT RIGHT.
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT ABOUT CAO
FIRE CAL FIRE RESPONDS WITH
COORDINATION WITH LEADERSHIP AND
ALSO EXTENDS TO OUR LOCAL FIRE.
FIGHTING DEPARTMENTS TO
COORDINATE IN A MAGNIFICENT --
COMING TOGETHER YOU'VE GOT A
LEADERSHIP TEAM THAT ALSO MOVES
AROUND THE STATE.
THAT MY PURPOSE ON BEHALF OF
THOSE RESIDENTS YOU'VE SERVED IN
MY DISTRICT IS TO SAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS AND I HOPE YOU
AND I'M ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MONNING
SKINNER SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
THEN COLLEAGUES --
I WANTED TO STAND AND ALSO --
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO
DIRECTOR OF OP DIE.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I WAS ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND THEN.
ON THE CITY COUNCIL IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AMBER SIDE COUNTY OF THE
MUNICIPALITIES CONTRACT WITH CAL
FIRE TO BE THERE EITHER CITY
FIRE DEPARTMENT OTHER COUNTY
FIRE DEPARTMENT.
AND I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT THE
GROSS RECEIPTS OF CAL FIRE
YOU'LL SEE THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
IS ONE OF THE LARGEST --
PARTNERS IF YOU WILL WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE THE
FINEST FIREFIGHTERS --
ON THE PLANET THAT --
COME FROM CAL FIRE IN SOME OF
OUR MUNICIPAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND AND THAT
CERTAINLY HASN'T HAPPENED BY
CHANCE HAPPEN BECAUSE WE HAD
GOOD LEADERSHIP --
WE HAVE SOME VERY CHALLENGING
TIMES OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY GOING
BACK TO THE ESPERANZA FIRE WHICH
REMEMBER WAS A ARSON FIRE THAT --
UNFORTUNATELY FOUGHT THE LIVES
OF FIGHTERS WHICH IS SOMETHING
MISSING GREEN AND AND IN MY SOUL
AND CERTAINLY A TWO AND A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
AND THEN ALSO THERE WAS A AND
EFFORT WHEN I FIRST GOT ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AMHERST
ICON IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE MY
PREDECESSOR WANTED TO MOVE.
THE AIR ATTACK BASES THAT WE HAD
HEMET RYAN WHICH WAS CLOSE TO
THE MOUNTAINOUS AREAS OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY TO MARCH
AIRFIELD.
WHICH WOULD HAVE BECAUSE THE
AIRCRAFT TO HAVE TO GO BY A
CERTAIN FEDERAL FLIGHT PATH AND
THEN GET TO THE DESTINATION IT
WOULD HAVE CAUSED.
AT LEAST A FORTY FIVE MINUTE TO
AN HOUR DELAY TO GET TO THE MORE
FIRE PRONE AREAS RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND WE WORKED WITH.
DIRECTOR* LAUDE ON THAT AND
ENSURING.
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WILL
THAT WE THEN RE DIRECTED AND
KEPT THAT YOUR TACK BE SEPTEMBER
RYAN WORD IS TODAY.
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
THE DIRECTOR TO DO SOME
REFURBISHMENTS A GOES BACK TO
THE THIRTY YEARS OF THE FORTIES
OF THE CONSTRUCTION THERE --
BUT IT'S A GOOD DIRECTOR
PENALIZE CERTAINLY HELPED US
MOVE THE BALL FORWARD IN
ADDRESSING THE MODERNIZATION OF
THIS AIR ATTACK BASES SO I WANT
TO WISH YOU GOOD HEALTH.
AND GOOD FORTUNE IN YOUR
RETIREMENT AND AND AGAIN YOU
LOOK VERY YOUNG TO BE RETIRED.
BUT I KNOW THAT YOU'VE STILL GOT
A LOT OF GREAT THINGS THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO DO IN YOUR YEARS
AHEAD WITH YOUR VAST EXPERIENCE
AND IN FIRE MITIGATION AND AND
AND LOOKING POSSIBLY CAN'T OF
THE FIREFIGHTERS AND IMPORTANTLY
KEEP THEM SAFE.
PUBLISHER THE LUCKY.
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE
[inaudible]
AMERICANS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I THINK HE FINALLY GOT ONE GOOD
NIGHT'S SLEEP IS --
IS WHAT HAPPENED I I ALSO WANT
TO EXPRESS MY THANKS.
LONG BEFORE WE HAD THIS NEW
NORMAL SITUATION SAN DIEGO IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE IN --
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN UNTIL
RECENTLY HAD HAD THE HISTORIC
DESIGNATION OF ONE OF THE WORST
FIRES UNFORTUNATELY THAT HAS NOW
BEEN SHARED WITH TOO MANY OTHER
COMMUNITIES.
BUT I DID WANNA ON BEHALF OF ONE
OF MY PREDECESSORS AND MY MENTOR
FORMER SENATOR CHRISTINE KEY HOW
EXPRESS --
BECAUSE I KNOW FOLLOWING THOSE
FIRES THERE WAS A WHOLE AYE
EFFORT AROUND LOOKING AT
SERVICES SAFETY PUBLIC SAFETY
SERVICES AT THE STATE AND I KNOW
THAT SHE WORKED VERY CLOSELY
WITH YOU AS DID A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS.
BUT ON BEHALF OF GRATEFUL PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S AMAZING TO ME WE
ARE STATE OF FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE ALMOST.
AND THE NUMBER --
RECTALLY AND PERSONALLY
CONTINUES TO ASTOUND ME THAT YOU
ARE WILLING.
TO TALK WITH ANY OF OUR STAFFS
IN THE COMMUNITIES OUR COMMUNITY
LEADERS THAT YOU WORK WITH OUR
LOCAL FIRE SERVICES ON THE
GROUND IN EVERY COMMUNITY IN
THIS STATE.
ARE REALLY IS A TRIBUTE TO HOW
SERIOUSLY YOU HAVE TAKEN THIS
JOB.
OBVIOUSLY --
WE ARE THANKFUL. FOR THE WORK SO
ON BEHALF OF GRATEFUL
COMMUNITIES --
THE GRATEFUL CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA WE WISH YOU THE BEST
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE PROBABLY
STILL GONNA LOSE SOME NIGHTS
SLEEP BECAUSE I SEE THAT --
YOU OBVIOUSLY HAVE A MEMBER OF
YOUR FAMILY ALSO IN UNIFORM.
AND IT IS A GOOD LEGACY TO
FOLLOW OBVIOUSLY AND BUT AGAIN
WE STILL WISH YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY ALL THE BEST PLEASE ENJOY
IT WITH OUR GRATITUDE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS.
SENATOR JACKSON'S BUT I INVITE
THOSE OF SPOKEN TO COME WILL
TAKE A PICTURE THAN ANYONE ELSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO JOIN.
THANK YOU CHIEF HIM WHAT WE OWE
YOU A DEBT OF GRATITUDE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE ARE STILL UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR AND WE HAVE OUR NEWEST
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION HERE WITH US TODAY.
MOLINA COHEN LEAH CAN YOU GIVE
US A LITTLE WAVE WERE VERY HAPPY
TO HAVE YOU WITH US.
WELCOME AND CONGRATULATIONS
[inaudible]
POLLUTION.
SENATOR DODD FOR WHAT PURPOSE
SIR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
INTERACTION WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SO TODAY FROM OUR MEAL HIGH
SCHOOL WE HAVE TO STUDENTS
JULIANA MOJICA ELIZABETH FLORES.
WE'VE GOT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OF SLAUGHTER COUNTY CHRISTIAN
ABRAMS AND WE'VE GOT THE MULTI
MEDIA ACADEMY TEACHER
COORDINATOR MISS LORI GOOD SALAS --
AS A CONTEXT JULIANA IN
ELIZABETH SUBMITTED THE WINNING
ENTRY FOR THE ANNUAL POWER OF
KINDNESS STUDENT VIDEO CONTEST
WHICH IS SPONSORED BY SOLANO
COUNTY SUPERVISOR JON VASQUEZ IN
SOLANO COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
KRISHNA ABRAMS ALL GRADES SEVEN
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS OF
SLAUGHTER COUNTY ARE INVITED TO
ENTER INTO REGIONAL VIDEO SHORT
ON HOW THE POWER OF KINDNESS.
CAN BE USED TO MAKE A POSITIVE
DIFFERENCE AGAINST BULLYING IN
OUR SCHOOLS HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES AYE WHITE TO WISH
THEM.
THE STUDENTS --
TO CONGRATULATIONS AND ALSO HAVE
THEM STAND TO BE RECOGNIZED BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WARM WARM WELCOME
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU.
SENATOR MCGUIRE AT SENATOR
HERTZBERG STASHED GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR MCGUIRE
GOOD AFTERNOON AND HAPPY NEW
YEAR MADAM PRESIDENT IT IS WITH
GREAT HONOR.
TODAY THAT I RECOGNIZE THE
SISTER CITY DELEGATION OF
CRESCENT CITY IN BEAUTIFUL DOWN
OUR COUNTY.
ALONG WITH THE DELEGATION FROM
RE CRUISING TEN OCT A CADA JAPAN
THAT SAME EVENT THAT TOOK OUT
THE FUKUSHIMA NUCLEAR POWER
PLANT.
A SMALL BOAT A SMALL BOAT.
BELONGING TO TO KIND OF HIGH
SCHOOL IN JAPAN.
SO WAS SWEPT OUT TO SEA.
THAT SAME BOAT ARRIVED ON THE
SHORES OF CRESCENT CITY.
IN BEAUTIFUL DEL NORTE COUNTY
TWO YEARS LATER.
STUDENTS TO DOWNLOAD HIGH SCHOOL
BANDED TOGETHER TO BE ABLE TO
FIX UP THE VESSEL.
AND SEND IT BACK TO TO CUT A
HIGH SCHOOL AS A GOOD WILL
GESTURE.
THESE TWO SCHOOLS WHOSE
RELATIONSHIP STARTED WITH
TRAGEDY.
BEGAN LAW A LIFE CHANGING
INITIATIVE IN PARTNERSHIP AND
LAUNCHES A STUDENT EXCHANGE
PROGRAM AND ESTABLISH A SISTER
SCHOOL RELATIONSHIP IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
WE LIKE THE BILL TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE CITY AND COUNTY
OFFICIALS FROM BOTH HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES AS WELL AS JAPAN.
ALONG WITH THE COUNCIL GENERAL
OF SAN FRANCISCO FROM THE GREAT
COUNTRY JAPAN FORM BARKING ALONG
A LAST SEEN SISTER CITY IN
SISTER SCHOOL RELATIONSHIP.
THAT WILL PROVE BENEFICIAL FOR
BOTH NATIONS IN THE GOLDEN STATE
FOR DECADES TO COME ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE
WELCOME THE DELEGATION TO THESE
ARE CHAMBERS.
COLLEAGUES A WARM WELCOME TO OUR
GOOD FRIENDS FROM THE NATION OF
JAPAN
.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR
WHAT PURPOSE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
IN THE MATTER LOUNGE PLEASE
COLLEAGUES TO DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
IN THE MADDIE LOUNGE
THE CARCASSES
HAVE CONCLUDED WE ARE BACK. TO
WORK ON THE DAILY FILE AT THIS
POINT IN TIME.
BUT STILL UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR.
SENATOR GLAZER AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK.
SENATOR GLAZER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS COLLEAGUES WE'RE BACK IN
SESSION [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
SENATOR GLAZERS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
I WOULD ASK AT MEMBERS ON THE
FLOOR TO JOIN ME TODAY AND
WISHING A FINE FELL WHAT CARE
WELL. TO ERIN RYAN WHO IS THE
PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT TO THE
SENATE INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
I SHE IS RETIRING LATER THIS
WEEK.
CHANCES ARE THERE HAVE ONLY BEEN
ONE PRINCIPLE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT.
IN THE HISTORY OF THE SENATE.
WHO ALSO HAD CAREERS AS A
CONGRESSIONAL AIDE?
A PROFESSIONALLY TRAINED PASTRY
CHEF.
AND A. C. I. A. ANALYST.
THAT DISTINCTION BELONGS TO ERIN
RYAN.
WHOSE WINDING PATH OVER THE
COURSE OF AN EXTRAORDINARY LIFE.
BROUGHT HER NOT ONCE BUT TWICE
TO OUR OWN INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
I HAD THE PLEASURE OF GETTING T
KNOW HER LAST YEAR.
AS THE CHAIR OF THE PANEL.
I'M SORRY TO SEE HER GO BECAUSE
IN THE SHORT TIME WE HAVE WORKED
TOGETHER.
SHE ADDED A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT TO
MY INSURANCE LAW I. Q..
BUT BEFORE SHE GOES I WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SHARE WITH
YOU SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS OF
AARON'S LIFE.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND AROUND
THE WORLD.
THOSE WHO OF WORK WITH ERIN NO
THAT SHE CAN BE A TENACIOUS
ANALYSTS.
GRABBING HOLD OF A PROBLEM AND
REFUSING TO LET GO UNTIL SHE
KNOWS IT AS WELL AS ANYONE. TO
UNDERSTAND THAT TENACITY.
IT HELPS TO KNOW A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT.
HER FAMILY FROM WHERE SHE CAME
[inaudible]
AARON'S FATHER [inaudible]
LEO RYAN.
WAS A PROUD IRISH AMERICAN AND A
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
SAN FRANCISCO FIRST ELECTED IN
THE EARLY NINETEEN SIXTIES.
HIS EARLY CAMPAIGN FEATURED
APPEARANCES BY THE RYAN GIRLS.
ERIN AND HER TWO SISTERS.
WHO DRESSED IN GREEN AND ORANGE
OUTFITS ON BY THEIR MOTHER? TO
CELEBRATE THE FAMILY'S ETHNIC
HERITAGE.
NOW WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
OVERSIGHT IN THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT LEO RYAN DID MORE THAN TALK.
HE WAS A BORN INVESTIGATOR.
AFTER THE WATTS RIOT.
RYAN WENT TO LOS ANGELES IN WORK
AS A SUBSTITUTE TEACHER TO GET A
FIRST HAND LOOK AT CONDITIONS IN
THE AREA.
LATER AS CHAIRMAN OF A COMMITTEE
OVERSEEING PRISON REFORM.
HE POSED AS A DEATH ROW INMATE
AT FOLSOM PRISON. TO GATHER
INFORMATION ON PRISON CONDITIONS
FOR HIS COMMITTEE.
AND AS MANY OF YOU KNOW.
LEO RYAN'S LIFE ENDED TRAGICALLY.
AMID YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THIS
THERE IS FOR INFORMATION.
THE LEE ALL SERVING IN CONGRESS
AARON'S FATHER WAS ASSASSINATED.
ON A SOUTH AMERICAN AIRSTRIP
WHILE INVESTIGATING THE
JOHNSTOWN ENCAMPMENTS.
WHICH HOUSE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
DRAWN FROM HIS DISTRICT IN SAN
FRANCISCO. TO JOIN A CULT KNOWN
AS THE PEOPLE'S TEMPLE.
ERIN WAS JUST TWENTY ONE WHEN
HER FATHER WAS KILLED
[inaudible]
IS WORK AND HIS DEATH.
WERE THE INSPIRATION FOR HER IN
PUBLIC SERVICE.
HE EARNED A BACHELOR OF SCIENCE
IN FOREIGN SERVICE AT GEORGETOWN
UNIVERSITY.
AND A LAW DEGREE FROM HASTINGS.
HE THEN SERVED EIGHT YEARS AS AN
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER IN THE CIA.
FOR JOBS INCLUDED ADDING THE
PRESIDENT'S DAILY BRIEF AND
BRIEFING THE SECRETARY OF STATE
AND THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE.
HE LATER SPECIALIZED IN LATIN
AMERICA AND AFRICAN ISSUES.
SHE WAS THE PRIMARY AUTHOR OF
THE NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE
ESTIMATE ON SOUTH AFRICA.
AT A TIME OF INTENSE DEBATE AND
UNREST AT THE END OF THE
APARTHEID ERA.
BUT THIS WORK TOOK ITS TOLL.
AND AARON NEEDED A BREAK.
SO SHE PACKED HER BAGS FOR NEW
YORK IN PURSUIT ANOTHER PASSION
FOR ANOTHER KIND OF SERVICE WITH
THE DIFFERENT.
CIA THE CIA WAS THE CULINARY
INSTITUTE OF AMERICA.
AND IN HIGH PARK WHERE SHE
ATTENDED THE THEIR INSTITUTE A
SHE GOT A GREAT EDUCATION RETURN
TO CALIFORNIA'S A PASTRY CHEF.
IN SAN MATEO COUNTY IN
SACRAMENTO INCLUDING AT THE
HYATT REGENCY ACROSS THE STREET
FROM THE CAPITOL.
BUT AFTER LEARNING HOW TO MAKE
PASTRY WITH THE BEST OF THEM.
ERIN DECIDED TO SEE HOW THE
LEGISLATIVE SAUSAGE WAS MADE.
THAT'S WHAT SHE CROSSED THE
STREET TO JOIN THE STAFF OF
SENATOR JACKIE SPEAR.
JACKIE HAD WORKED FOR LEO RYAN
AS MANY OF YOU NOW.
WAS SHOT FIVE TIMES AND LEFT FOR
DEAD IN THE SAME AMBUSH THAT
KILLED AARON'S FATHER.
JACKIE AND ERIN'S FAMILY HAD
DEEP TIES SO IT WAS A PERFECT
MATCH OF SENATOR AND STAFF.
AARON SERVICE JACKIE'S
LEGISLATIVE AIDE IN LATE LATER
AS A CONSULTANT. TO THE BANKING
FINANCE INSURANCE COMMITTEE HE
ROSE TO BECOME PRINCIPAL
CONSULTANT UNDER CHAIRMAN MIKE
MACHADO.
HE THEN FOLLOWED SENATOR SPEAR
TO WASHINGTON.
AFTER SEVERE WAS ELECTED TO
CONGRESS AMONG OTHER ISSUES ERIN
PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN
REPRESENTING JACQUI ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT.
AND THE DODD FRANK LAW THAT
REFORM THE FINANCIAL SERVICES
INDUSTRY AFTER THE HOUSING CRASH
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE JACQUI
WANTED TO BE HERE TODAY.
BUT SHE COULD NOT BE ABSENT FROM
HER DUTIES IN WASHINGTON.
HE SENT ME A NOTE DESCRIBING ERA
HAS QUOTE ONE OF THE SMARTEST.
MOST DEDICATED AND RESOURCEFUL
PUBLIC SERVANTS SHE'S EVER MET.
ERIN SHE SAID WAS A REMARKABLY
TALENTED LEADER AND WE KNOW THAT.
IT WAS A STAND OUT IN EVERYTHING
THAT SHE TOUCH.
AFTER FIVE YEARS IN WASHINGTON
ERIN'S LOVE FOR CALIFORNIA ONCE
AGAIN TO HER BACK TO THE STATE.
THIS TIME TO COMPLETE CAREER.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
ERRANT'S BEEN A PRINCIPAL
CONSOLE INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
IN OUR WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE
ERIN'S HOW HELP CRAFT
LEGISLATIVE COMPROMISES. TO
PRESERVE THE CALIFORNIA
EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY.
STAFF HEARINGS ON CATASTROPHIC
THREATS FACING CALIFORNIA FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE DROUGHT AN
EARTHQUAKE.
ERIN IS A CONSUMER AND
PROFESSIONAL DEDICATED TO HER
WORK TO THE SENATE AND TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT SHE ALSO KNOWS HOW TO ENJOY
YOURSELF AND SHE HAS A LOVE FOR
TRAVEL FINE WINE AND HORSES.
I WISH YOU THE BEST A SHE LEAVES
THE SENATE TEAM AND TRADES LATE
NIGHT AT WORK FOR A CHANCE TO
RIDE LITERALLY.
INTO THE SUNSET [inaudible]
CONGRATULATIONS [inaudible]
I WARNED.
MARTY THANK YOU.
MEMBERS I REYES TO TEACH ME ALSO
RATE IS WE HAVE TO BE RECOGNIZED
BY THAT I'M READING OF THE STORY
[inaudible]
CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU UP MEMBERS I RISE TO
ALSO RECOGNIZE HER I'VE ONLY
HAVE THE REASON PLEASURE OF
KNOWING AARON BUT IT DOESN'T
TAKE MUCH. TO RECOGNIZE HER
PROFESSIONALISM COMPETENCE AND
PASSIONATE FOR CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS SHE HAS A DEEP RESPECT
FOR THE SENATE THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND STUFF.
THAT RESPECT IS ME TOO I LIKE TO
SHOW A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT
WERE SHARED WITH ME BY OTHER
PEOPLE.
AT CENTER GLAZER MENTIONED
ALREADY MANY WHO KNOW HER ARE
IMPRESSED WITH THE BREADTH OF
HER BACKGROUND NOTING THAT SHE
GRADUATED FROM TWO CIA'S AS HE
MENTIONED EARLIER.
THE CENTRAL INTELLIGENCE AGENCY
IN CULINARY INSTITUTE FOR THE
ARTS THIS ELECTRIC BACKGROUND
HELPS TO EXPLAIN HOW SHE BECAME
SO PERSISTENT.
KNOWLEDGEABLE AND GENEROUS ONE
OF OUR FORMER SENATE COWORKERS
ONCE HOUSE IF SHE HAD A FUN
MEMORY WHEN SHE WORKED IN THE
CIA.
SHE REMARKED THAT DURING HER
TRAINING SHE ENJOYED.
WHO CAN SAY THAT BUT WHILE FEW
PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT HER TIME
PROTECTING THE COUNTRY FAR MORE
HAVE TASTED HER ACCOMPLISHMENTS
AS A PASTRY CHEF?
WHEN AARON FIRST JOINED THE
SENATE ONE OF HER COLLEAGUES
WOULD CAUTION ALL THE LOBBYISTS
AND ANYBODY THAT WOULD COME
CLOSE TO HER THERE'S TWO THINGS
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND ABOUT
AARON?
FIRST SHE'S SMARTER THAN YOU AND
SECOND SHE'S WEAPON TRAINED.
DURING THOSE YEARS SHE FOUGHT
TIRELESSLY TO IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF EARTHQUAKE AND FIRE VICTIMS
AS WELL AS IMPROVE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR LIFE INSURANCE
PRODUCTS ESPECIALLY THOSE SOLD
TO SENIORS.
ALTHOUGH SHE'S MOVING ON WE WILL-BUILD ON ERRANT'S EFFORTS THIS
YEAR AND THE YEARS TO COME AND
BELIEVE ME I TRIED VERY HARD TO
CONVINCE HER TO STAY WHEN WE HAD
OUR LITTLE SIT DOWN.
I AM SORRY AGAIN TO SEE HER GOAL
BUT WE ALL WISH YOU'RE VERY WELL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE ERIN.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO AND
AGAIN A WARM.
AND WELL DESERVED RETIREMENT
SENATOR ROTH ON THIS.
YES BETTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES --
I'VE KNOWN AIR AND SINCE I WAS
FIRST ELECTED TO THIS --
STATE SENATE IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND I'VE
SERVED ON THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE SINCE THE TIME BUT IT
WAS NOT UNTIL I WAS.
THE INSURANCE COMMITTEE CHAIR IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN FOR ABOUT TWO
YEARS THAT I REALLY HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO WORK --
CLOSELY WITH HER NOW.
I'M NOT GONNA REPEAT THE WELL
DESERVED ACCOLADES OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SPOKEN OF AND
THEY ARE EXTRAORDINARILY WELL
DESERVED --
BUT I WILL SAY THAT --
AS A STAFFER MYSELF FOR MOST OF
MY THIRTY TWO YEARS IN THE
AIRFORCE AND HAVING SERVED AS A
COMMITTEE CHAIR OR SUB COMMITTEE
CHAIR ON ONE COMMITTEE OR
ANOTHER AROUND HERE FOR NOW
GOING ON WHAT WILLBE.
SOON SEVEN YEARS I THINK I KNOW
WHAT A GREAT STAFF LEADER LOOKS
LIKE.
AN I CAN SAY THAT AARON IS ONE
OF THE BEST IF NOT THE BEST.
STAFF LEADER THAT I HAVE EVER
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
WITH AND FOR ACTUALLY.
IN OR OUT OF THE MILITARY.
AND YES I HAVE TRIED THE
PASTRIES.
NO KNOW TEARS IN THE SENATE.
NOW - AARON
YOU'LL REMEMBER THIS FROM YOUR
FEDERAL SERVICE BUT SENIOR
MILITARY OFFICERS HAVE A UNIQUE
WAY.
HAVE HAD AND CONTINUE TO HAVE A
UNIQUE WAY OF RECOGNIZING
SUPERIOR PERFORMANCE.
IT IS THROUGH THE PRESENTATION
OF SOMETHING IN A MILITARY WE
CALL A CHALLENGE ACCORDING.
AND SO ERIN.
I'M GONNA PRESENT YOU WITH MY
CHARGE GOING AND TELL YOU HOW
MUCH WE'RE GONNA MISS YOU.
I THANK YOU SIR ARE.
IN [inaudible]
WARMEST REGARDS.
PERHAPS THE SENATE NEED TO SHIP
[inaudible]
SENATOR MORNING.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
AS A FORMER CHAIR OF THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE IN THE
SENATE I ALSO JUST WANT.
TO OFFER MY THANKS TO ERIN FOR
HER AMAZING SUPPORT HER
CREATIVITY HER INNOVATION --
ONE BILL IN PARTICULAR THAT SHE
HELP NAVIGATE RELATED TO FIRE
VICTIMS IN OUR RECENT FIRES A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE WHO LOST A
LOVED.
ONE IN A IN A HOME THAT WAS
INCINERATED ALONG WITH THE
OCCUPANT THERE IS NO WAY TO
DETERMINE.
IF HE HAD LIFE INSURANCE FOR
FIRE INSURANCE BECAUSE
EVERYTHING WAS BURNED.
AND THE CONSTITUENTS HAD DIRECT
TO EVERY INSURANCE COMPANY IN
CALIFORNIA. TO SEE IF THEY HAD A
RECORD FROM THIS PERSON.
AND WE WORKED WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER IN THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY TO TRY TO THREAD THIS
NEEDLE BUT IT WAS AARON WHO CAME
UP WITH THE PLAN THAT ALLOWS A
SIMPLE.
ELECTRONIC ALERTING ANYONE
LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA THEY NOW
HAVE TO RESPOND TO THAT QUESTION
IF THEY HAVE A POLICY IN THE
NAME.
OF THE DECEASED WHO LOVED ONES
HAD NO WAY OF GETTING THAT
INFORMATION SO THAT'S JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF AARON'S CREATIVITY
AND PROBLEM SOLVING.
BUT AS A FRIEND THERE AND WE'RE
GONNA MISS YOU --
IN ADDITION TO THE WORK YOU ARE
ALSO REALLY FUN TO HANG OUT WITH
SO ALL THE BEST TO YOU IN YOUR
NEXT COOKING CAREER.
THANK YOU SENATOR MONEY.
SENATOR GLAZER.
AND T CONCLUDE THAT MADAM
PRESIDENT TO HONOR AND RECOGNIZE
AND THANK YOUR AND WE'RE HAVING
A RECEPTION FOR HER ROOM IN ROOM.
TO ELEVEN AT THAT THIS POINT
TIME SO MEMBERS AS WE COMPLETE
OUR BUSINESS AND STAFFERS IN THE
BUILDING --
PLEASE COME DOWN AND SAY OUR
THANKS TO ERIN AGAIN THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
BEGAN HARDIEST CONGRATULATIONS
AND BEST WISHES ON YOUR
RETIREMENT.
OUR COLLEAGUES WE WILL MOVE ON
ARE THERE ANY OTHER PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR.
SEEING NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
I'M SORRY SENATOR DODD.
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
JOURNEY MEMORY WE ARE.
GOING TO GO THROUGH AND REPORTS
SO A OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED --
WE WILL GO TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
ARE THERE ANY THING NON.
WE WILL DO INTRODUCTION OF FIRST
READING OF BILLS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL ONE THIRTY ONE ONE THIRTY
TWO WOULD SET UP A ONE THIRTY
THREE THANK YOU.
NOW WE WILL RETURN TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND THIS IS
INDEED THE TIME TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY WE HAVE SEVERAL THAT AE
LISTED --
WILL START SENATOR DODD --
IF YOU'D LIKE TO START.
AND THEN GO TO SENATOR WIENER I
BELIEVE WAS NEXT.
AND SENATOR SKINNER.
SENATOR DODD MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY ASKING WE JOURNEY
MEMORY OF OFFICER NATALIE KURODA.
TRAGICALLY OFFICER CORONA PASSED
AWAY ON JANUARY TENTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AFTER SHE
WAS AMBUSHED SHOT AND KILLED
WHILE RESPONDING TO A ROUTINE.
CAR CRASH IN THE CITY OF DAVIS
AND MY DISTRICT.
SHE SUCCUMBED OR INJURIES AT UC
DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER IN
SACRAMENTO.
SHE WAS ONLY TWENTY TWO YEARS
OLD.
FROM OUR BUCKLE CALIFORNIA
NATALIE GRADUATED FROM PEERS
HIGH SCHOOL IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND WENT ON TO RECEIVE
HER ASSOCIATES DEGREE IN
ADMINISTRATION.
OF JUSTICE FROM YUBA COLLEGE.
FOR AS LONG AS ANYBODY CAN
REMEMBER NATALIE HAD ALWAYS
WANTED TO BE A POLICE OFFICER.
YEAH SHE STARTED AS A COMMUNITY
SERVICE OFFICER AT THE DAVIS
POLICE DEPARTMENT EVEN AFTER
FUNDING FOR POSITION ENDED HE
CONTINUED TO SHOW UP TO WORK AS
A VOLUNTEER.
SHE WAS DETERMINED TO DO WHAT
SHE LOVED.
IN JULY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
SHE GRADUATED FROM THE
SACRAMENTO POLICE TRAINING
ACADEMY IN AUGUST SECOND OFFICER
KRONE WAS SWORN INTO THE DAVIS
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
SHE'D COMPLETED --
FUEL TRAINING JUST BEFORE
CHRISTMAS [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
AND THOSE WHO --
THOSE WHO KNEW HER QUICKLY TOOK
NOTICE OF HER TO BE A RISING
STAR AT THE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
DEMONSTRATED BY HERSELF LIST
THIS HER HUMILITY IN OUR HARD
WORK ETHIC.
THOSE CLOSEST TO HER NEW HER
PASSION ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IN OUR COMMITMENT TO SERVING THE
COMMUNITY.
OFFICER CROWN IS SURVIVED BY HER
FATHER MERCED WHO IS SERVE FOR
TWENTY SIX YEARS WITH THE COLUSA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
AND NOW SERVES AS A COLUSA
COUNTY DISTRICT ONE SUPERVISOR.
SO PUBLIC SERVICE WAS VERY MUCH
IN THEIR BLOOD.
HER MOTHER LUPE CORONA AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER IN OUR
BUCKLE.
IN HER YOUNGER. THREE SISTERS
JACQUI KATHY AND CINDY OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES ARE EXTENDED
OFFICER CROWN FAMILY FRIENDS AND
THOSE WHO WORK WHETHER.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
AND DEDICATION TO SERVING AND
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITY PLEASE
JOIN ME IN A TURNING IN MEMORY.
OF OFFICER NATALIE CORONA THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH THANK EDITOR
DAUGHTER ON THIS SHOULD TURN IN
MEMORY SENATOR NIELSEN.
GOT A PRESERVATION GENERAL THE
SENATE THIS IS WITH A HEAVY
HEART. FOR I KNOW THE FAMILY.
END OF LONG REPRESENTED THAT
TINY LITTLE TOWN OF OUR BUCKLE.
IN HISTORIC.
COLUSA COUNTY.
AND WHEN SOMETHING HAPPENS LIKE
THIS IN SUCH A SMALL COMMUNITY.
IT BURNS THE THERE'S NO MASSIVE
POPULATION. FOR A TO BE IMMERSED
IN AND FORGOTTEN ABOUT
[inaudible]
DISREGARD.
EVERYBODY KNOWS EVERYBODY ALMOST
TO THE DEGREE THAT THEY ALL FEEL
RELATED.
AND THAT COUNTY.
AND THIS YOUNG LADY WAS QUITE A
QUITE A STARK.
IN ALL MANNER IN WAY.
HER FAMILY HAD A LONG TRADITION
I BELIEVE ROUND TWELVE THE
CORONA FAMILY HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND HER FATHER PARTICULARLY THE
DISTINGUISHED OFFICER.
I TALKED WITH THE SHERIFF NIGHT
BEFORE LAST ABOUT OR SAID IN HIS
CAREER [inaudible]
AND THEN.
THIS CROSSES MY MIND IS ONE
WHO'S BEEN A LOT OF TIME IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
HOW DOES?
ONE LIKE MR CORONA.
HAVE THE CHILD FOLLOW IN THEIR
FOOTSTEPS.
THE CHILD CHILD WANTS TO DO THAT.
BUT THEN SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPENS.
THAT BURDEN SURELY MUST BE
GREATER.
AND A LOT OF IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THEIR FAMILY.
MUST BE ALL THE GREATER. TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT.
WAS A BRIGHT.
WONDERFUL CAREER AHEAD OF THIS
YOUNG WOMAN.
AND SHE STARTED IT.
IN THE CITY OF DAVIS.
A FAIRLY QUIET.
VERY SAFE COMMUNITY.
SUCH THINGS AS THIS RE OFFEND
THE VALUE.
THE COMMUNITIES LIKE DAVIS.
AND COMMUNITIES THAT ARE VERY
DIFFERENT LIKE ABA.
BUT IT MUST TOUCH ALL OF OUR
HEARTS AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
PLEASE ADD.
THE CORONA FAMILY [inaudible]
YOUR PRAYERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN AND
PERHAPS WE TAKE A VERY BRIEF
MOMENT OF SILENCE IN MEMORY OF
THIS YOUNG WOMAN.
WE COULD ALL STAND [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
SENATOR WIENER.
AT THE  I PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT --
COLLEAGUES --
IT IS WITH --
INCREDIBLE SIDE THIS --
THAT I RISE ACCOUNTS OF THE
SENATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
OF NORMAN TANNER --
SAN FRANCISCO RESIDENT AN
AMAZING AMAZING.
ARE COMMUNITY LEADER WHO ALWAYS
LEAD BY EXAMPLE AND WHO
TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY ON
OCTOBER FIFTH AT THE AGE OF
SIXTY TWO DAYS AFTER --
HE WAS HIT BY A CAR TING ACROSS
WALKING A CAR RAN A RED LIGHT --
HIT AND MANY DIED TWO DAYS LATER.
MAJOR LOSS FOR FOR MY COMMUNITY --
LIKE ME NORMAN GREW UP IN NEW
JERSEY AND MOVED TO SAN
FRANCISCO AS A YOUNG GAY MAN --
TO PURSUE HIS FUTURE --
AFTER RECEIVING AN HIV DIAGNOSIS
IN --
NINETEEN NINETY NORMAN BECAME
EVEN MORE ENGAGE AS A LEADER IN
THE COMMUNITY --
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX HE
FOUNDED BLACK BROTHERS A STEAM --
PROGRAM OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
AIDS FOUNDATION --
WHICH BECAME OUR CITIES FIRST
SUPPORT GROUP --
FOR LGBT AFRICAN AMERICAN MAN --
KNOWN AFFECTIONATELY AS STORMING
NORMAN --
SHE WAS ALSO A LEADER AND SAN
FRANCISCO'S --
SOBRE COMMUNITY WHERE HE MEANT
TOWARD A HUGE.
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
STRUGGLING WITH ADDICTION AND
HELP PEOPLE GET HEALTHY AND STAY
HEALTHY.
HI A LOT OF PEOPLE'S LIVES WERE
CHANGED FOR THE BETTER --
BECAUSE OF NORMAN.
HE ALSO TOOK THE TIME --
TO FOCUS HIS MENTOR SHIP.
ON PRISON INMATES AND OTHER
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS WHO ARE
OFTEN OVERLOOKED IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST ADDICTION --
AND HE MAINTAINS HIS COMMITMENT
TO PROGRESSIVE CAUSES THROUGHOUT
HIS LIFE.
HE'S ALSO ONE OF THE KINDEST
PEOPLE I'VE EVER MET --
IN OUR COMMUNITY ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE THAT YOU AT DIFFERENT
MEETINGS AND EVENTS AND HE'S
JUST ALWAYS HAD --
NICE THINGS TO SAY SOMETIMES IT
WELL AS AN ACTIVIST AND WE'VE
ALL BEEN THERE --
IT'S TIME TO THE BECOME VERY
ANGRY AT THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE AND HE WAS ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE.
WHO HAS ALWAYS HAD A POSITIVE
UPBEAT OUTLOOK AND IT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HELPED HIM
INSPIRE AND MENTOR --
SO MANY PEOPLE TO GET THEIR
LIVES.
BACK ON TRACK.
HE IS SURVIVED BY EXTENDED
FAMILY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING HIS MOTHER AND
SIBLINGS AND HIS NIECES AND
NEPHEWS --
HE WILL BE DEEPLY DEEPLY MISSED
BY MANY MADAM PRESIDENT I ASK
THAT THE SENATE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF NORMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU WOULD
TO BEFORE THE END OF THIS
SESSION BRING.
A NAME FOR WHICH WE CAN PROBABLY.
PROPERLY FOR MORE MEMORIALIZE
HIS NAME THANK YOU.
DID YOU HAVE A SECOND
ADJOURNMENT ONLY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
COLLEAGUES --
IT'S WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I I
ASKED THE JUDGE THE SENATE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY --
OF A LONG TIME --
SAN FRANCISCO RESIDENTS TO
NICHOLSON WHO PASSED AWAY ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FIFTH --
BORN IN SAN FRANCISCO --
SO PUBLIC EVENTS PLANNER FOR A
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE
COLLEGE OF MARIN --
SHE WENT ON TO PURSUE HER
INTEREST IN INTERVIEWS AND
BROADCASTING AND IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY I SEE FOUNDED THE
RENOWNED ORGANIZATION CITY ARTS
LECTURES PROBABLY HEARD ON NPR --
BEFORE --
FOR DECADES SHE BROUGHT --
FAMOUS INTERVIEWERS INTERVIEWEES
TOGETHER ON STAGE IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOR AND UP.
CONVERSATIONS --
REALLY AN AMAZING ORGANIZATION --
AFTER THIRTY SEVEN YEARS OF
INCREDIBLE WORK --
MISS GOLDSTINE PASSED THE
LEADERSHIP OF CITY ARTS LECTURES
TO HER DAUGHTER KATE GOLDSTINE
PRIOR.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER DAUGHTER
KATE HER SON JOSEPH PRIOR HER
HUSBAND --
UNITED STATES DISTRICT JUDGE
CHARLES PRIOR --
HER SISTER DOREEN LEWIS AND
THREE GRANDCHILDREN SHE WILL BE
DEEPLY MISSED AND I ASKED THE
SENATE ADJOURNED AND HER MEMORY.
I THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER AND
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD BRING THAT
NAME FORWARD AND CONDOLENCES TO
THE FAMILY PLEASE [inaudible]
SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES ON DECEMBER
FIFTH BERKELEY LOST A VERY
TREASURED RESIDENT AND ANY OF
YOU WHO EITHER STUDIED AT CAL --
DON'T GIVE IT AWAY.
VISITED THERE OR LIVED THERE
WILL KNOW EXACTLY WHO I AM
REFERRING TO WHEN I TELL YOU
THAT BERKELEY LOST THE BUBBLE
LADY.
JULIE HAVE BEEN A GRAD PASSED
AWAY.
AT AGE SEVENTY FOUR FROM COLON
CANCER SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER
SISTER DEBBIE WHO ALSO LIVES IN
BERKELEY.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
ALL KNEW ABOUT JULIA IS THEN IN
ADDITION TO BEING THE BUBBLE
LADY SHE WAS A STREET POET.
SHE WROTE OVER SIXTY FOUR
VOLUMES OF POETRY SHE SOLD THEM
ON THE STREET NOW WAS HER SOURCE
OF INCOME --
SHE WROTE ABOUT BERKELEY'S
STREET LIFE AND CULTURE.
AND SHE GAVE AN IDENTITY AND
HUMANITY TO ARE HOMELESS
RESIDENTS BECAUSE SHE VERY
COMMONLY WROTE ABOUT THEM.
NOW HOW DID YOU COME ABOUT TO BE
THE BUBBLE EIGHTY BECAUSE AT A
PEOPLE'S PARK DEMONSTRATION
WHICH WAS GETTING QUITE TENSE.
SHE BROUGHT BUBBLES WITH HER AND
THEN WALKED UP AND DOWN THE LINE
OF THE OFFICERS WHO WERE IN RIOT
SQUAD AND BLEW BUBBLES.
IN IN THAT PARTICULAR INSTANCE
THE OFFICERS RESPONDED CURRENTLY
AND IT DID BRING DOWN THE
TENSION AND FROM THAT POINT ON
SHE ALWAYS HAD BUBBLES AND
CERTAINLY AT EVERY DEMONSTRATION
SHE BLEW BUBBLES.
I'M IN TWO THOUSAND FOR THE CITY
OF BERKLEY HONORED HER WITH A
LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT AWARD IN
GAVE HER THE MONIKER OF THE
UNOFFICIAL POET LAUREATE FOR THE
CITY OF BERKLEY.
HE WON NUMEROUS AWARDS INCLUDING
THE AMERICAN BOOK AWARD FROM THE
FOR THE COLUMBUS FOUNDATION.
AND BEFORE I ASK THE SENATE TO
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY.
I WOULD LIKE TO DO THIS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
SO ASKED THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
THE MEMORY.
OF JULIA BEEN A GRAD THE BUBBLE
LADY.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER PLEASE
BRING HER NAME FORWARD.
SO SHE WE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
BY THE SENATE [inaudible]
SENATOR CABALLERO.
THANK YOU MADAM.
PRESIDENT UP TODAY I RISE TO ASK
THE SENATE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF RANDY ELK ON A TRULY
REMARKABLE INDIVIDUAL.
WHO IS HIGHLY REGARDED FOR HIS
INDOMITABLE SPIRIT?
HIS ON HIS DEMEANOR AND FIND
PERSONAL CHARACTER AND
COMMITMENT EXHIBITED IN HIS
DECADES OF WORK AND LEADERSHIP
AND THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
MOVEMENT.
A NATIVE OF CALIFORNIA RANDY WAS
BORN IN FRESNO ON NOVEMBER FIFTH.
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE TO IRENE
KERNS AND MELVIN GONE BEGAN HIS
CIVIC ACTIVISM WHILE ATTENDING
HUMBOLDT STATE UNIVERSITY WHERE
HE ORGANIZED PEACEFUL PEACEFUL
DEMONSTRATIONS TO PROTEST THE
VIETNAM MORE.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE HE
JOINED THE BAKERY CONFECTIONERY
AND TOBACCO WORKERS UNION AT THE
PERFECTION MACARONI FACTORY IN
HIS LONG AND DISTINGUISHED
CAREER IN THE LABOR MOVEMENT.
BY AGE TWENTY THREE RANDY WAS
ELECTED AS THE FIRST SHOP
STEWARD IN THE FACT FACTORIES
HISTORY AND SUBSEQUENTLY LANDED
A SPOT ON THE UNION'S BARGAINING
TEAM.
IN THE YEARS TO FOLLOW HE HELD
POSITIONS OF INCREASING
RESPONSIBILITY WITHIN THE LABOR
MOVEMENT. FOR SIXTEEN YEARS
RANDY PROVIDED VISION AND
STRATEGIC LEADERSHIP AS DIRECTOR
OF THE CLC PARTNERSHIP WHICH
PROVIDES EMPLOYMENT READINESS
SERVICES AT THE WORKFORCE
CONNECTION IN MANCHESTER CENTER
IN THE COUNTIES OF FRESNO AND
SAN MATTEO.
IN NINETEEN NINETY WAS ELECTED
TO THE POSITION OF IT EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY TREASURER OF THE
FRESNO MADERA TO LARRY KING'S
CENTRAL LABOR COUNCIL.
THERE HE WAS NAMED LABOR LEADER
OF THE YEAR NOT ONCE BUT TWICE.
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO AND TWO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND HE WAS THE
ONLY MEMBER TO RECEIVE THIS THIS
HONOR TWICE.
OVER THE COURSE OF HIS MORE THAN
FOUR DECADES AS A LEADER HE
SHARED THE EXPERTISE AS
TREASURER OF THE BORDER
REGENERATE CALIFORNIA INNOVATION
AND INCORPORATED A FRESNO BRICK
BASED NONPROFIT CORPORATION THAT
MANAGES COMMUNITY AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS.
AND HE WAS PRESIDENT OF THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION LOCAL.
SEVEN FIFTY TWO ON A MORE
PERSONAL LOAN I ATTENDED THE
SELF.
VALUE LABOR COUNCIL LABOR DAY
BREAKFAST --
THAT THEY HELD THIS PAST YEAR
AND I'M TOLD THAT HE WAS REALLY
INSTRUMENTAL IN GETTING THIS
STARTED THERE MUST HAVE BEEN
BETWEEN THREE AND FOUR HUNDRED
PEOPLE THAT ATTENDED WITH
CHILDREN IT WAS INCREDIBLE.
AND AGAIN IS THE PERSON WHO TO
BE ABLE TO CELEBRATE LABOR IN
THE VALLEY.
HE'S REMEMBERED NOT ONLY FOR ITS
EXPERTISE IN INFLUENCE IN THE
LABOR COMMUNITY BUT ALSO FOR
BEING A LOVING AND DEVOTED
FAMILY MAN.
HE ADORED SPENDING TIME WITH HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHO REMEMBER
HIM FONDLY FOR HIS INFECTIOUS
LAUGH AND GENEROSITY OF SPIRIT.
PRECEDED IN DEATH BY HIS LOVING
PARTNER OF THIRTY SEVEN YEARS
SHARON HODGSON HIS PARENTS IRENE
KINDS AND MELVIN GONE.
RANDY GONE LEAVES LEAVES TO
MOURN HIS PASSING AND CONTINUE
HIS LEGACY HAS MANY EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBERS INCLUDING HIS
DAUGHTERS MARIA JORDAN AND TRACY
JORDAN HIS GRAND CHILDREN
ANTOINE JORDAN AND ANGELA.
AND ANTOINE WINFIELD ISAAC
JORDAN JIMMY JOHN AND MIA
GONZALEZ HIS GREAT.
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN HIS SISTER
AND BROTHER Là BROTHER IN LAW
AND A HOST OF OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS AND MANY LONG TIME
FRIENDS AND THE COUNTLESS
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE WHOSE LIFE HE
IMPROVED.
WE JOIN IS FAMILY AND FRIENDS
TODAY IN CELEBRATING THE LEGACY
OF A DISTINGUISHING CARING
INDIVIDUAL.
AND WE ASK THAT WE INJURED IN
HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU CENTER CAL AERO CENTER
HER TADO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I WISH
TO ALSO CHEN IN MEMORY OF RANDY
CON.
AS WE KNOW IT FEARS LABOR LEADER
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHO PASSED
AWAY ON DECEMBER SEVENTH.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN RANDY
HOWARD DURING EXECUTIVE BOARD OF
THE CENTRAL LABOR COUNCIL IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND
EVENTUALLY BECAME THE BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE ENTIRE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
BUT ASIDE FROM ALL OF HIS GREAT
WORK IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
IN THE LABOR MOVEMENT --
AND HIS CAREER ACCOMPLISHMENTS
RANDY WAS AN INCREDIBLE HUMAN
BEING AN EXTRAORDINARY FRIEND
AND JUST.
AN AMAZING MENTOR.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS TRULY AT A
LOSS OF HIS LIFE IS A STORY
MARKET SOCIETY SIX FASTING
COMPASSION FOR THE ISSUES HE
HELD THE DEAR TO HIS HEART.
AND FOR THE COMMUNITY.
HIS INFECTIOUS LAUGH WILL BE.
DEEPLY MISSED BY ANYONE AND
EVERYONE WHO SPENT TIME IN HIS
PRESENCE I KNOW I WILL.
REST IN PEACE RESTAURANT POWER
MY FRIEND.
THANK YOU CENTER HER TADO CENTER
BORDERS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I WANT TO DO --
ALSO JOINED IN WITH --
MY ON FELLOW --
VALLEY DELEGATION ON MEMBERS OF
THANK YOU CENTER COVER YOUR FOR
BRING THIS --
ADJOURNED ADJOURNMENT MEMORY UP
TODAY BACKGROUND I I HAD
OCCASION TO TO GET TO GET GET TO
KNOW RANDY --
VERY WELL IN --
IN FRESNO POLITICS AND FRESNO
WAS SERVICE --
WE SERVED TOGETHER ON THE
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARD AND I
GOTTA TELL YOU HE TAUGHT ME A
LOT --
DURING OUR DURING OUR TIME
TOGETHER --
HE TAUGHT ME THAT --
COLLEGIALITY.
I AM POSITIVE INTERACTION GO A
LONG WAY.
IN EVEN WITH FOLKS THAT MAY
DISAGREE PHILOSOPHICALLY ON A
NUMBER OF ISSUES --
THERE WERE PLENTY OF THINGS THAT --
WE DISAGREED ON POLITICALLY BUT
I ALWAYS CONSIDERED HIM A FRIEND
THAT HE ALWAYS CONSIDER ME A
FRIEND.
AND WE LOST A GREAT LEADER A
GREAT UNION LEADER IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD AND HE WILL
CERTAINLY BE MESSED.
SO -- OUR
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS GO OUT.
TO THANK YOU SENATOR BORDERS
CENTER CABALLERO PLEASE MAKE
SURE HIS NAME IS BROUGHT
FORWARDS WE CAN PROBABLY
MEMORIALIZE HIM CENTER JACKSON.
IT'S THANK YOU A COLLEAGUE SO I
STAND TO CHURN IN THE OF A AN
EXTRAORDINARY.
LEADER.
OF A WOMAN WHO REALLY WAS CALLED
THE GODMOTHER OF TITLE.
NINE HER NAME WAS DOCTOR BERNICE
SANDLER BETTER KNOWN AS BUNNY
SAMPLER.
SHE DIED AT THE AGE OF NINETY
AND LIVED IN EXTRAORDINARY LIFE
WHICH I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
BRIEFLY WITH YOU AS WE CONTINUE
TO FIGHT. FOR EQUALITY OF
OPPORTUNITY.
BACK IN THE THIRTIES AND FORTIES
WHEN SHE WAS A SCHOOL GIRL.
SHE WAS ANNOYED AND THAT'S
PROBABLY NOT HER WORD BUT SHE
WAS ANNOYED THAT SHE WASN'T
ALLOWED TO DO THINGS THAT THE
BOYS WERE ALLOWED TO DO LIKE BE
A CROSSING GUARD.
OR OPERATE THE SLIDE PROJECTOR.
SHE WAS A GIRL AND SHE WASN'T
ALLOWED TO DO THAT DON'T ASK ME
WHY GIRLS COULDN'T DO THOSE
THINGS BUT THEY WERE NOT ALLOWED
TO DO SO.
SHE DID GO ON HOWEVER. TO GET
HER DEGREE IN PSYCHOLOGY FROM
BROOKLYN COLLEGE IN NINETEEN
FORTY EIGHT HER MASTER'S IN
PSYCHOLOGY.
FROM CC AND WHY.
SHE GOT A DOCTORATE IN EDUCATION
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT NOW SHE
EXPERIENCE BETWEEN THE TIME SHE
GOT HER MASTER'S AND WENT ON FOR
DOCTOR.
SHE XPERIENCED HER SELF THE
DISCRIMINATION AS YOUNG ACADEMIC
IN THE SIXTY SHE WAS TOLD BY
UNIVERSITY DEANS THAT SHE WAS
PASSED OVER FOR TEACHING
POSITIONS.
BECAUSE SHE QUOTE CAME ON TOO
STRONG FOR A WOMAN.
I'M LOOKING AROUND THIS ROOM
HERE.
AND THAT MAY HAVE APPLIED TO ALL
OF US HERE.
OF OUR GENDER.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO BE TOO
STRONG FOR WOMAN?
WELL.
SHE WAS VERY VERY ANNOYED BY
THAT.
THE ACT A SUGGESTION.
AND OUR CLAIMS THAT SHE WENT
HOME AND CRIED.
BUT SHE GATHERED UP HER COURAGE
SHE DID SOME READING AND
DISCOVERED THAT.
THERE WAS A LITTLE KNOWN CLAUSE
IN AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
THE PROHIBITED AMONG OTHER TYPES
OF DISCRIMINATION.
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON GENDER
IN AWARDING FEDERAL CONTRACTS.
THAT HAD BEEN --
PUT INTO AN EXECUTIVE ORDER BY
THEN PRESIDENT LYNDON BAINES
JOHNSON.
WELL THAT WAS HER EUREKA MOMENT.
SHE WAS NOT TRAINED IN THE LAW
OR LEGISLATIVE PRACTICE BUT SHE
USED THE FEDERAL ORDER TO FILE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS IN OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CASES.
AGAINST THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ACTIONS WHICH LED TO THE
EVENTUAL CRAFTING OF TITLE.
NINE NOW SHE RECEIVED MULTIPLE
AWARDS DURING HER LIFE DOZENS OF
HONORARY DEGREES AND WAS
INDUCTED INTO THE NATIONAL
WOMEN'S HALL OF FAME IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN BUT OF THE MANY
STORIES THAT I'VE READ ABOUT
BUNNY.
MY FAVORITE IS THE ONE WHERE THE
COST MOST CLUBS IN WASHINGTON DC
DIDN'T ALLOW WOMEN UNTIL
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND IF YOU
WERE.
GOING TO BE ASKED TO SPEAK THERE
YOU AS A WOMAN W'RE SUPPOSED TO
GO IN THE BACK DOOR.
WHICH SHE REFUSED TO DO.
AND BECAUSE SHE WAS SO ANNOYED
BY THIS SHE CARRIED WITH HER
DOZENS OF OF THE STICKERS THAT
SAID UPPITY WOMEN UNITE.
AND ONE OF THE WAITERS AT THE
COSMOS CLUB HE ASKED HER FOR
HANDFUL OF THEM WHICH HE THEN
DISPLAYED IN THE URINALS IN THE
MEN'S ROOM.
MUCH TO THEIR CONSTERNATION BUT
TO HER PLEASURE.
AND TO OUR PLEASURE I SUSPECT
THE WORD WAS OUT.
SO I SAY IN THE FORTY SEVEN
YEARS SINCE TITLE NINE WAS AND
ENACTED EVERY WOMAN IS GOING TO
COLLEGE GOTTEN A LAW DEGREE OR A
MEDICAL DEGREE.
OR WAS ABLE TO TAKE --
SHOP INSTEAD OF HOME ECONOMICS.
OWES DOCTOR SANDLER GREAT DEBT.
TO GENERATIONS NOW OF WOMEN
DOCTORS LAWYERS AND ATHLETES CAN
LOOK AT HER WORK TO FOR EXAMPLE
TO HER INTELLECT TO HER
DETERMINATION. TO HER BEING
ANNOYED BY NOT BEING ABLE TO
OPERATE THE SLIDE PROJECTOR BACK
IN THE THIRTIES AND FORTIES.
SHE WAS INDEED THE START OF IT
ALL SHE SPENT DECADES OF OUR
LIFE IN THE FIGHT FOR WOMEN TO
BE SEEN AS EQUALS AND TO BE
JUDGED NOT ON THE BASIS OF THEIR
SEX.
BUT ON THE CONTENT OF THEIR
CHARACTER.
THANK YOU DOCTOR BERNIE SANDLER
FOR A LIFE WELL LIVED FOR
HELPING SO MANY OF US AS WE HAVE
A TRIED TO NAVIGATE AND FIGHT
FOR EQUALITY FOR OURSELVES AND
OUR DAUGHTERS AND OUR SISTERS.
AND FOR THOSE YET TO COME.
GOD BLESS YOU.
REST IN PEACE.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON PLEASE
BRING DOCTOR SANDLER'S NAME
FORWARD FOR PROPER MORE
REALIZATION.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS.
MADAM PRO TEM THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I WOULD.
CLOSE BY REMINDING MY COLLEAGUES
IT WILL RECONVENE ON FRIDAY NOT
THURSDAY ON FRIDAY AT NINE AM IN
THE CHAMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM THE
SENATE IS ADJOURNED AND WE WILL
RECONVENE FRIDAY AT NINE AM HAVE
A GREAT DAY EVERYONE